when you talk about withholding
techniques or Folsom techniques they are
both manipulations but one is an act of
manipulation whether and what is a
passive manipulation so if I'm actively
manipulating you you do not have to do
anything I will I will do everything for
you I will keep you busy I will tell you
how to feel at every single moment but
if I am passively seeking your emotions
I'm you have to start to come toward me
and that starts to become your journey
and your journey will always be
different than your journey and your
journey whereas my active Journey it's
going to be the same for all of you I'm
going to make you all sort of feel the
same buzzes at the same time and scream
at the same time and but if I'm doing a
passive Journey it will be different and
when people start to fill out the vacuum
they start to project themselves into it
and therefore you know when people say
what's the real meaning of that I said I
don't know you tell me Iris DeMent has a
great song called Let the mystery be and
sometimes you know that's the hardest
thing for an artist to do is let the
mystery be